sur le plateau châtillonnais une
véritable oasis voulu et dessiné par
l'homme depuis octobre dernier la fosse
de coulmiers a droit à sa cure de
jouvence là on voit bien là la première
noire que jamais personne n'a vu avant
six architectes maçons redonne vie à ce
bassin unique
bâti au xviiie siècle un peu au milieu
de nulle part
ce qui est étonnant c'est le contraste
entre la magnificence de l' ouvrage 10
mètres de diamètre six mètres de hauteur
avec une maçonnerie qui a appareillé
splendide et puis la modestie du propos
récupérer les eaux de ruissellement pour
alimenter un village sans cours d'eau et
sans source
c'est la fonction première de ce bassin
digne d'un château à l'époque une eau
vital pour l'élevage et des habitants du
village y compris pour les plus nantis
il se peut que ce soit un de ces grands
propriétaires étrangers qu'ils aient
incité la population à construire cet
ensemble qui esthétiquement par son
esthétique et son volume est tout à fait
exceptionnel en milieu rural puis
l'avoir et réserves d'eau pendant plus
de 200 ans
le bassin finira vandalisée à la fin du
xxème siècle sa singularité lui
permettra d'être finalement inscrit aux
monuments historiques
en 2010 et pour trouver des dispositifs
comme celui là il faut aller chercher
ailleurs dans le monde
en terre sainte en palestine en chine
mais on n'a pas trouvé de dispositifs
équivalents aux france si la fosse n'est
aujourd'hui plus d'utilité coulmier le
sec la bien nommée reste vigilante sur
sa ressource en eau malgré une un
captage au niveau de la scène et des
citernes d'un dans chaque habitation va
dans quelques habitations du village
la réserve d'eau falot reste toujours un
sujet sensible sur la comète sa
restauration terminé la fosse va ainsi
intégrer le circuit touristique du
châtillonnais un atout pour ce village
de 272 habitants